bradley better get on board and it's got
to happen in the next couple of days or
we got some hard decisions to make
hard for you at least we were looking
for a character who would be able to
banter with billy in my head the goal of
those characters they would have these
difficulties but they would forge a
relationship with stella she needs to be
as smart as her elders but with a very
different sensibility and when you meet
greta you'd see she had all that i don't
take it lightly
to be able to have this opportunity to
show
a young asian american woman in a
position of power it's happening in life
so we need to show it and to get to do
it with these people who i love it's
incredible
well i want to welcome back alex levy
when we did that dinner scene that was
the first time that all of us had been
together since the pandemic began i miss
the cast i miss not being able to see
them so when i get to see their faces
it's so nice to play the scene that is
about a reunification i found very
rewarding
you think trump is innocent but that's
not the point the point is it's a
charade the way genko is being judged
for his political ideas is very
illuminating are we even allowed to have
conflicting opinions anymore one of the
great things that kerry's done this
season is highlight that as a society we
want to put people in boxes how much
will it cost for you to get off my front
step
it's a complex set of emotions when
you're dealing with this character who
has done these terrible things and then
they come back and you're wondering am i
being asked to just hate this person am
i being asked to feel for them now and i
think that's going to be left up to the
viewer
i'm really sorry daniel
apology's not accepted i remember
thinking god he really is not hiding it
at all that was one of the first scenes
where we are reminded that everyone in
this environment is really really
ambitious
winning is a theme in our storytelling
corey wants to win mia wants to win they
all want to win the journey is getting
there
you